no they do say though the damage
accumulative it's a cumulative over I
think a period of like ten years from
the initial incident so I'd say if you
have a really bad car accident your
brain will continue to deteriorate for
ten years from the effects of that
accident when when the guy told me that
I was like how do you know and I don't
know how they know I don't remember he
kind of explained it but I was like so
you mean a guy who gets knocked out we
were at the fights when he's telling me
this so I'm like you tell me a guy who
gets knocked out today it's gonna feel
the real repercussions of that knockout
in ten years he's like yes it's very
possible that's the case Wow it's gonna
take ten years to show its full effects
so if you see someone who's [ __ ] up
now like if they've got brain damage now
like as time goes on it's gonna be like
like Muhammad Ali was one of the weirder
ones because he had developed a
neurological disease he developed
Parkinson's but there's but there's
trauma induced Parkinson's a lot of
people try to say no no no Ali got
Parkinson's it was a disease yeah maybe
but you know who else has Parkinson's
Freddie Roach the boxing coach and he
openly discusses the fact that it's
trauma-induced he got it from his long
boxing career just because it's a brain
disease doesn't mean the brain disease
didn't come from getting the [ __ ] beat
out of your brain I mean imagine if you
had a game that you played or people
like to kick you in the liver this is
the game you know you kicked me the
liver I kick you in the liver and then
later on you develop liver cancer and
people like yeah but he just liked to
drink oh he had sclerosis had nothing to
do with getting kicked a lot oh okay
nothing to do I'm sure he has a super
healthy brain after getting pounded on
for decades
that's ridiculous that doesn't make any
sense Jesus yes Jesus dude I have the
probably the most minor of brain damages
probably the most minor because I
stopped when I was 21 yeah what's your
number how many times I mean how many
times do you think like you like oh that
did damage how a hundred percent there's
a bunch of them there's a bunch of them
that I could think back getting rocked
and feeling my knees go like
getting punched in and then keeps bar
and keep sparring spar two more rounds
that guy spar three rounds with another
guy he's hitting you in the face too
like you didn't stop it was really dumb
he'd get hit and you get rocked and you
didn't nobody likes sat you down and go
okay let's take the day off now you get
right back in there man your [ __ ]
legs would go bang what your legs would
do and you cover up and you'd you know
people be throwing bombs on you and
you'd next day sparring again can you is
there a way to detect it like hit it
your brain scan see there's other ways
now there's better ways now but I had a
limited amount of it I mean I had the
real getting wrapped in the head for me
came when I tried to transition from
Taekwondo to kickboxing I do in
Taekwondo I got I definitely got hit in
the head for sure but I didn't get hit
in the head as much cuz it's hard to
kick people in the head you definitely
get hit I mean I don't know how many
times I definitely got hit but I never
got knocked out from a head kick but I
got knocked out from punches before all
right
at least keep TKO and I got tko'ed but
when when a punch hits your face it's
like your your legs go and everything
like shuts off like if you get rocked
and you see like a person go down it's
not that they go down like oh so much
pain I have to go down no you get hit
and everything shuts off it just goes
broke and then you feel your legs like
rubber you're trying to stand back up so
just watch the last UFC where Edson
Barboza head kicked Kevin Lee yes see I
see spinning wheel kicked him and you
see Kevin Lee's legs just go blank man
they just gave out for a second and then
he came back and those those ones I got
way more when I was boxing I got way
more of those like I was I was not good
at boxing when I first got into boxing I
was learned I was good at Taekwondo but
then I got into boxing I was not good at
it I didn't know what I was doing I
didn't understand the distance Taekwondo
you didn't punch in the face you only
punch the body so you had a real
distorted perception of how good you
were with your hands and then once I
started boxing I was like oh this is
terrible yes that's what I was taking
like probably the most damage of my life
of a period of like two years of like a
lot of sparring I did a lot of barn
everybody's barred everybody sparked
with everybody people knock people out
all the time stupid so stupid I see guys
get knocked out I mean out cold right
hand to the chin boom
eyes roll behind their head legs give
out they bounce off the canvas
they put a cold towel on them they put
some ice on his head he gets up he's
like I'm good I'm good I'm good you want
to keep going yeah let's keep going
let's keep going now you were just
unconscious you were just unconscious
five minutes ago and you want to keep
spar and this is crazy and they'd let
him they'd let him keep sparring you did
it from when you were like really young
right Tyco window from when I was I took
karate classes when I was 14 but when I
got super serious I was 15 it was like
right at mice before my sophomore year
of high school so like I got into it
from the time I was in the ninth grade
as I was 14 like that summer like right
after my birthday around is when I
started getting into so I was probably
either 14 or just turning 15 I was like
was there a point you could tell where
people actually could be able to knock
people out and give that damage because
there may be but 14 year olds to knock
you out all the time the thing about
kicks is almost anybody can knock you
out it's really crazy like when you
think of the amount of power that you
have to have like in your legs they say
if you decide to put a heavy backpack on
like one of those outdoorsman's Atlas
trainers and put 90 pounds on you could
walk up flights of stairs dude just
think of how much power that is in your
legs you could throw your body up
flights of stairs for exercise just to
lose your body is whatever you weigh 150
200 whatever you weigh your body is just
launching that through the air over and
over and over again even if you're a
girl that weighs 135 pounds you're still
launching 135 pounds through the air and
if that girl [ __ ] shins you Bo bling
right on your temple it goes across the
jaw temple area got blind your legs are
gonna give out your brains gonna shut
off if somebody hits you perfect there's
a video of I think the
was she I think it was I think it was
mighty mo mighty molly i believe he was
some Moen and I mean just like typical
Samoan dude big giant [ __ ] powerhouse
of a dude and he fought this little Thai
guy this tie guy was 175 pounds so much
smaller than I mean it was crazy to
watch the Thai guys just move it away
moving away moving away and then the
Thai guy roundhouse kicks him in the
head this guy like look at the
difference in size yeah and watch this
this dude just comes over the top I mean
the difference between the two of them
my Teemo is a beast too seriously
dangerous knockout puncher he put a lot
of guys to sleep so not as this guy in
there with someone way bigger than him
but he's in there with a killer but look
at that one head kick it mighty moe's
down and out did I mean back that up
again because that is a crazy thing to
watch you're talking about a guy who
might have been a hundred pounds lighter
than him and Mighty Mouse just a vicious
puncher bang you just clanged him right
in the head that's what I'm talking
about a girl does that to you
night-night son I was thinking more like
two ten-year-olds like no knock each
other out that's a good point because
the thought process is that if you teach
kids technique don't teach them to just
go in those wild [ __ ] haymaker
exchanges but teach them how to do it
correctly it's good to do it when
they're young because they don't hurt
each other because they have little tiny
arms and they just kind of touch each
other and they can't really generate
knockout power they just sort of and if
they learn how to do that from the
beginning and then develop knockout
power on the pads and on the bag then
you develop much more technically
proficient fighters rather than brawlers